sobias welcome to the future of Life
Institute podcast glad to have you on
perhaps you could start by introducing
yourself to our listeners yeah thanks
for having me
having me so my name is
Roman I'm a researcher at and co-founder
of the center for reducing suffering
which is a research non-profit
that tries to figure out what you can do
now to best reduce suffering taking into
account authentic beings and at the
long-term future I'm also the author of
a book called avoiding divorced which is
exploring potential worst case futures
of humanity and what we can do to
prevent them
all right so what are these suffering
risks that that you're worried about and
and why should we focus on them so
suffering risks are broadly defined as
worst case Futures that entail suffering
on an astronomical scale vastly
exceeding everything that has happened
so far
and I mean why should we focus on them
well because that will be very bad right
it's kind of it's self-explanatory that
the dose scenarios would be extremely
bad which is why it could be a
worthwhile to do something to prevent
that if you can so so one of these
scenarios that could cause a lot of
suffering is involves space colonization
maybe you could we could start there and
you could talk about how space
colonization could be risky and could
potentially create a lot of suffering
yeah so I mean I suppose the relevant
bit is is simply that it would massively
raise the stakes that
um
it would presumably result in an overall
explosion of the size of human
civilization of the overall population
size so if Humanity expands throughout
the Universe then everything is kind of
scaled up by a factor of not just 10 or
100 but like by a factor of a million or
a billion if you imagine
a future
Interstellar Intergalactic civilization
so the stakes would be higher by many
orders of magnitude so even if only the
the existing forms of suffering continue
that they have they now happen on a
larger scale so that would already be an
asterisk
um although it is worth noting that the
relationship between space expansion
into space and astronomical scale scales
is is not so straightforward because if
you have a situation where we really I
don't know builds sporadic outposts
somewhere or or mine some sort of
asteroids or something like that then
that in and of itself would not be so
relevant so I mean the key question is
like that it but that it would raise the
stakes that it would would result in an
explosion of the size of of human
population of Freeman civilization do
you think all of the worst possible
suffering events in the future involve
space colonization or do you think that
that space condensation is is is the
biggest suffering risks because it's
it raises the stakes so much yeah I mean
this sort of ties back to the expected
value framework right an argument can be
made that scenarios that involve space
colonization are just so much larger in
scale than many orders of magnitude that
we should focus on on them
even if those scenarios are not
necessarily the most likely I'm not
saying that space colonization is
necessarily likely I mean the sort of
large-scale space pronunciation in fact
maybe I'm fairly
I'm fairly skeptical about that because
what exactly would even be the
motivation you know why exactly does
Elon Musk need to go to Mars like it's
just the baron Wasteland with weird
gravity and like no atmosphere so so why
exactly what exactly is the point of
expanding into space you're far away
from running out of available space on
Earth so yeah one can sort of wonder why
exactly space colonization would happen
but I mean that is an intention with
like the the argument like the the EV
framework and the largest things if
space pronunciation happens so
so you think that Humanity in the future
wouldn't necessarily be motivated to
venture into space to expand into space
at least it's not so obvious to me I
mean it's just it's subject to the the
usual great uncertainty about the future
I I would say that I'm neither super
confident that space condensation will
happen nor super confident that it will
not happen
but I I was just saying that I'm
wondering about what exactly would the
motivation be other than that it's kind
of cool to expand into space but like
yeah it perhaps one uh big large
motivation is just that it would be an
awesome Testament to to what uh humanity
is able to achieve but if we're talking
more in terms of more the objective
value of uh of trying to to conquer
other planets for example or trying to
extract resources then perhaps one thing
would be that if we had control over
things that that that are large-scale
risks on Earth such as nuclear weapons
and engineered pandemics and perhaps
artificial intelligence then if we're if
we're only sitting on Earth then we're
just waiting to be destroyed by an
asteroid or a super volcano or another
type of of natural risk if we hadn't
expanded into space so perhaps that
could be a motivation to go to space
that's beyond the accelerating feeling
of of seeing a rocket fly and and humans
on the moon and on Mars and so on
possibly
um I mean okay there's still a question
of that but I do it is worth the costs
um whether or not
I mean you can also just have a bunker
in Antarctica somewhere even if you have
nuclear war Earth is still less
inhospitable than Mars probably because
Mars doesn't have an atmosphere so I
mean yeah I don't know but perhaps that
could be a reason to do it but
that is just the reason to have an
output an outpost somewhere right
another reason to
colonize every planet and uh
so then there's one point
yeah and of course there's a difference
between whether you believe it's a good
idea that that humans should attempt
space colonization and whether you
predict that humans actually will
attempt space colonization and I as I
understand you you think that we will
actually attempt to colonize space and
that this could constitute just racing
the stakes enormously which which also
includes erasing the stakes of a lot of
future suffering
um is that somewhat correct yeah I mean
I'm just saying it it is a it is a
possibility and because that possibility
would vastly raise the stakes it's an
unexpected value framework it seems to
be worth thinking about these futures
and the the suffering beings we're
talking about if we colonize space are
these uh humans or are we also thinking
that we will perhaps bring along with us
animals or which beings could suffer in
a scenario where we colonize space uh it
could in principle be both humans as
well as
animals like some sort of factory
farming on a larger scale as well as
potentially wild animals I mean this is
um certainly speculative but I mean yeah
maybe humans could bring wild animals to
to other planets and then that would
sort of multiply
the scale of wild animal suffering
it could also be future artificial mines
I mean I would actually say that the the
question of which beings are affected by
by suffering is kind of orthogonal to
Independent of the question of whether
or not we expand into space at least in
principle presumably scenarios that
involves large scales basically
colonization are like they involve more
advanced technology so maybe it is more
likely that in those scenarios you would
also have
artificial sentences or Advanced Ai and
so on
um
but it is still important to disentangle
those different factors like whether we
colonize space is one factor whether or
not there would be a population
explosions another Factor just don't
necessarily have to go hand in hand and
whether or not we have advanced AI is
yet another Factor so I think there's
sometimes a tendency in long-termest EA
discourse to just throw all of that
together and you know we're going to
have ai and then it's going to call a
nice space and then we will have 10 to
the power 50 humans or beings in the
future but like
it is possible that some of those things
happen but not others that there is a
possibility to be mindful of yeah and we
should also perhaps flag here that you
are not only interested in preventing
suffering that arises from space
colonization you're in fact very
interested in in researching what might
cause suffering in the future in in
general and so we should at least as I
understand you we should we should keep
an open mind as to which types of
suffering risks might materialize in the
future there is an interesting
blog post by Robin Hansen where he's
arguing that yeah it's called a Galaxy
on Earth I think where he's arguing that
it could actually also have a huge
number of beings on Earth if you really
optimized for it if you build like huge
skyscrapers or like underground or
something like that if you use all
available space you could have a huge
number of beings even just on Earth even
without colonizing space so that's
something to be to also be aware of so
we're so in this scenario we're thinking
at the edges of physics how how many
conscious beings can be supported by
Earth
um if we dig kilometers into the ground
and build kilometers into the sky is
something like that yeah I mean
there is a you can of course wonder
whether or not that theoretical limit is
very uh relevant uh or whether or not
such scenarios are realistic it seems
far-fetched to think that we would do
that but like on the other hand who
knows okay so we should we should walk
through some examples that you've uh
that you've written about about how we
might go about preventing suffering
risks and and trying to prevent future
suffering so one of these uh Avenues is
to do a moral advocacy and this involves
what you call
um expanding the moral Circle if I
remember correctly this was a term that
the philosopher Peter Singer came up
with uh originally intended to in to
describe the situation where we begin to
include animals into our circle of moral
concern but um which which beings would
you advocate for
um being included into our moral circle
now yeah I mean I think there are many
steps to the circle like the
smallest possible morning circle is kind
of when they care about myself then the
next step would be something to care
about myself and my family and friends
and then the next step would be I don't
know my Village and my tribe then my
entire nation
then all of humanity and then humanity
and animals and then all sentient beings
or something like that
so in terms of beings that are currently
excluded a large category is definitely
non-human animals that's farmed animals
in particular we do care a little bit
about dogs and cats but of course we
should
care just as much about pigs and
chickens that are suffering often in in
terrible conditions on our factory farms
and slaughterhouses so that's that's one
important way in which the model Circle
needs to expand
another point that is often forgotten
even by animal activists is that of
animals living in nature because they
actually do constitute the vast majority
of scented beings on on Earth right now
our animals are wild animals animals
living in nature and of course their
well-being their suffering matters just
as much it would be a mistake to think
that they don't matter merely because
they because it's not directly
influenced by humans or something like
that did another step that is perhaps
where we're starting to enter like maybe
more speculative territory uh is that of
like very small animals invertebrates or
insects where it's just not entirely
clear whether those are sentient so it's
not clear whether or not those should be
included but it's at least a possibility
and then an even more speculative
possibility is that of artificial
sentience which I've already
mentioned potentially you could have
sufficiently complex computer programs
or simulations artificial Minds that
develop sentience and have developed the
capital
and it's again very unclear whether that
that will happen but it's realistic but
the point is that if such sentient
beings exist then their well-being
matters morally so if we think about
moral Circle expansion as a tactic for
trying to reduce future suffering do you
see any potential downsides with that
tactic could it backfire in specific
ways yes I mean it certainly could I
think one important backfire is to be
aware of is that you could trigger a
backslash against this idea it could
become a polarized topic of of political
discussion it could become a culture War
thing I mean there are various
variations of that maybe people would
just think that it's crazy and that
would obviously be very bad maybe people
would think that it's that it
constitutes at this a sort of disloyalty
to your own tribe Nation whatever that
you care so much about all of those
weird Minds you know
so that's perhaps a reason why people
would react would be hostile to this
idea and so it's important to
communicate
these ideas carefully and to emphasize
cooperation
uh when you're talking about those
things and to avoid needlessly
antagonizing
others what about simply being
empirically wrong about which Minds to
include so say that we are uncertain
about whether insects are conscious and
then we decide anyways based on the the
risks involved
um perhaps based on the expected values
uh calculations we've made to advocate
for their inclusion into the the moral
Circle but it turns out that we're wrong
that is potentially a high stakes uh bet
that that's that's being made if if the
the scientific consensus in 50 years is
that insects are not conscious and then
we then we have um perhaps wasted
resources or a cried wolf about
um beings that that turned out to to not
uh be able to feel pain or or pleasure
anyways yeah that is certainly the risk
I mean and even if one thinks that on a
sort of precautionary principle because
that insects might might matter a lot uh
it's still a strategic question of
whether or not it is wise to emphasize
this aspect in public advocacy so that
that's also something to be to be
mindful of one can I also wonder whether
it is particularly helpful to divide
things up in this way because like
ultimately what matters is to convince
people of the idea that all scented
beings matter you know no matter whether
they're
biological or artificial or like human
or non-human or or living in nature or
whatever so ideally you would convince
people of this this abstract
philosophical idea that all something
beings matter I'm not necessarily saying
that it's easy
but that will sort of be the ideal to
have a movement for all scented beings
and that certainly seems to be your your
ethical starting point um what what
makes you so convinced of this idea
so I mean the arguments that have been
made by Peter Singer and and others are
that it would just constitute a an
arbitrary form of discrimination to say
that some beings don't matter because
they belong to the the wrong so to speak
species and that that would just seem
like an arbitrary form of unjustified
discrimination to me like what matters
is that there are that there is someone
suffering and that that matters morally
though I mean I've always found that
intuitive this sort of line of argument
but I appreciate that it comes down to
moral intuitions and maybe other people
will feel differently about that and I
and I think other people throughout
history and and even in in today's
academic philosophy and so on uh they
they have felt differently they have a
thought that these uh what what could
seem like arbitrary distinctions uh
actually matter so that perhaps humans
are are
worth more than animals be in in virtue
of the fact that we are humans how
seriously would you take uh the fact
that that a lot of people disagree with
um with this care for all sentient
beings yeah so if I've always tried to
be nuanced and
but like this was maybe one thing where
I would be inclined to say that those
people are simply wrong it's worth
noting that we're here not talking about
empirical objective facts which is
talking about value judgments about
about moral philosophy and it is simply
my point of view is that that all Center
beings matter equally that I care and
Care equally regardless of our species
membership
is this perhaps could we frame this as a
as a bet you're making in a sense that
say that human the human civilization we
we become more rational we become more
collectively intelligent and
compassionate over the next 100 years
say and your bet is then that that
people would come around to your view
and what would abandon the the views
that that not all uh sentient beings
matter so perhaps it's it's uh it's a
it's some form of empirical prediction
about the ethical views that will be
held in in a century from now
well I mean whether or not we we will be
becoming more rational or ethical that
that is like an entirely different
question like sorry so you're asking if
we do become more ethical and rational
then I think that people would probably
move more towards an anti-speciesist
view more towards taking all sentient
beings into account indeed it is already
worth noting that like while there is
disagreement among philosophers on that
there is a substantial number of people
that do agree with this point of view
much more so than in the general
population I think
right so in a sense it is already true
that the people who have thought about
this the most
you have reflected the most about modern
philosophy are formed far more
positively inclined towards an animal
rights view towards taking authentic
beings into account
then
quote unquote the Layman let's talk
about which emerging Technologies could
potentially have a have a large effect
on on the the risk of future suffering I
think what's on the top of of everyone's
mind uh recently or many listeners to
this podcast will be interested in
artificial intelligence so perhaps you
could talk about the
the combination of uh how important will
it be to shape the the future of AI from
the the perspective of trying to reduce
future suffering yeah that's a great
question and so it is
quite possible that artificial
intelligence Advanced artificial
intelligence will be a very important
technology that shapes the future to a
large degree
comparable to perhaps something like the
Industrial Revolution though I mean this
is again one of those things where I'm
saying that it's uncertain and neither
confident that it will happen nor
confident that it will not happen so but
you could make a similar argument to the
one about space colonization that the
stakes will just be much higher if such
Advanced Technologies will be developed
which is why it's it's worthwhile to
think about those scenarios or and to
focus on them
even if it's not necessarily what you
think is is most likely we can maybe
discuss them lightly and separately but
still there's that argument to be made
but then it's a somewhat different
question like when you you mentioned I
think shaping the development of our
official intelligence and that's that
raises the question of like what exactly
does shaping it mean I think there's a
bit of a a common mistake perhaps to
jump to the conclusion that direct
technical work on AI safety is like the
this is an implication of the idea that
that AI is important therefore we need
to do technical work on AI safety but
this um I think it's not so simple
because other interventions such as
moral advocacy or or improving uh our
political discourse anything basically
that you could do that broadly
influences the longer future I mean this
would still affect AI outcomes right it
would indirectly affect them after all
AI development does not happen in a
vacuum
uh so it's it's intertwined with broader
social and political Trends and so even
in a world in which like even if you
know that there will be advanced
transformative AI in the year 2100 say
it's possible it's still possible that
the most impactful thing to do now would
would be moral advocacy rather than
trying to directly shape AI so there's
this distinction which I think is
important uh perhaps one argument
against this is to say that when we're
talking about AI safety what we're
talking about is is trying to make a an
AI system or AI systems in general
behave according to what we want so we
we are aligning them with our
preferences and that seems to me to be a
necessary condition for for aligning
them with any ethical view so perhaps uh
solving or working on AI safety is
necessary to imbue AIS with the values
we want whatever those values may be
what do you think do you think that AI
safety is is necessary in that way so I
mean there's maybe a couple of things
that that could be said about that maybe
my first thought on it is that maybe
this aspect of making it do what what
humans want it's probably not going to
be very neglected right because uh
I mean everyone is going to want that an
AI that is a system that is just
intelligent but doesn't do what you want
is is not doesn't do you much good right
um so perhaps this aspect is less
neglected and we should focus on
something that is that is more neglected
also when people talk about alignment
with human values I mean what human
values you know some human values are
not that great from my point of view as
someone who cares about authentic beings
so it's not true that merely aligning
the system with
some notion of what humans want would
necessarily prevent uh asterisks it
could still result in bad outcomes
because average human values are let's
just say that they're problematic in
some ways so from a purely asterisk
focused perspective I would say that
it's perhaps better to focus on on other
aspects like such as avoiding conflicts
between between AI that that could
result in in asterisks okay perhaps we
should go into that then so avoiding um
conflicts between AIS uh was the does
this link to your your work on
Cooperative AI yeah so perhaps you could
explain what uh what is cooperative AI
so Cooperative AI is a research field
the subfield of artificial intelligence
that is aiming at creating
artificial agents AIS that can
productively navigate cooperation
problems social dilemmas things like
that the prisoner's dilemma in their
interactions with both other artificial
agents and humans and so this goal of
achieving Cooperative AI is is different
from
tier maximization of capabilities or
intelligence which is what is usually
considered to be the goal of aim
yourself
which is why it's a subfield so I mean
we can talk a bit more about the precise
goals and definition of what cooperation
means and so on which is not entirely
clear in the various conceptual
questions there
but so just briefly explain like the the
connection to asterisks is that many
worst case scenarios can arise from when
you have escalating conflicts especially
high-stakes conflicts potentially
involving future technology
it is easy to see how that could result
in in very bad outcomes and so having
more Cooperative AI is a way to to
mitigate these risks if you have more
positive sum cooperation then the risk
of those worst case outcomes from
conflicts is lessened and so that that
is why
many people are interested in Esther's
production think that Cooperative AI is
like a promising thing to look at
the picture you're painting of of future
AI development here is uh if I
understand it correctly a picture in
which there are there are many AIS
interacting with each other and
interacting with humans perhaps that
that is a bit different from what other
people might imagine other people might
be inclined to imagine one two or or
three a uh large AI systems that are
powerful enough to to influence
um the entire world do you think this
and and why do you why do you believe
that that AI development might be more
dispersed and uh we might have thousands
or millions of of AIS as opposed to one
two or three
yeah so I mean again as opposed to the
field of Cooperative AI is kind of aimed
at scenarios where you have more than
one system because if you have just
everyone I mean I suppose you could
still imagine scenarios where you
encounter alien civilizations or you
have some sort of a causal Game Theory
uh thing involving other universes okay
but like bracketing that
if you have one agent then of course
that there are no cooperation problems
so yeah the field is kind of premised on
having separate agents one thing that's
worth noting is that you could have a
situation where you you at first have
many different AIS and then they just
kind of compete and at some point
only one takes over that that still
leaves you with
cooperation problems or potential
conflict like in the in the period
leading up to that that point right so
in that case it would still be relevant
now uh you were asking
whether or not
How likely it is that there is going to
be a single agent uh personally I don't
think
I wouldn't view that as too likely just
on the basis of historical Trends it
seems to me that the the prediction that
you will just that all power will be
Consolidated into a single system I mean
what exactly would be the evidence
for that view I wouldn't rule it out
either but it doesn't seem too likely to
me it seems to me that the most Natural
Evolution would be for like many
different actors to all develop their
AIS and when we are worried about
ai's
um interacting and we want them to
cooperate as opposed to
interact in hostile ways are we are we
drawing on lessons from history so are
we are we drawing on on humans
interacting with each other are we
trying to to import some of the some of
the lessons that that we've learned
there and perhaps as an additional
question here humans do not seem to have
solved the problem of corroboration so
how can we how can we hope that that we
can teach AIS how to cooperate yeah I
mean it's definitely true that
cooperation problems have been something
that is just been like a sort of
ubiquitous and perennial problem of
humanity and one that we have certainly
not completely solved probably never
will completely solve uh although I mean
in some aspects we have solved it to
some degree like uh I mean Stephen Baker
makes that case that violence has
declined Within
a certain Society things are now
nowadays surprisingly peaceful in some
ways
um certainly more so than they have been
in the past because we have things like
the police justice system and so on that
is created we've created in institutions
and incentive structures that that mean
that it just doesn't
make much sense to randomly kill people
on the street yeah and that actually
works so like that cooperation problem
that's something that we've solved
through a large degree at least
so can we program AIS or train AIS in
ways that make them better than humans
at cooperating possibly um
the question this is one of the
conceptual issues with with Cooperative
AI is that it
comes down to a degree uh
to whether or not the operators even
even want their their AI to be
cooperative because I can say that
like I mean I don't necessarily want if
I have this AI that manages my personal
finances I don't want it to say that
like oh but it will be most Cooperative
to give the money to someone who needs
more well okay
maybe but like if people are not going
to use that sort of system they want a
system that just pursues their own
interest and so there's a bit of a
question of of what exactly
the goal is but I nevertheless think
that there's some
scope to do to do useful things here
because when we build AIS we sort of
building those systems from scratch
we're probably gonna
have regulations institutions governing
the interaction between those AIS and so
at this sort of starting point you might
have a lot of Leverage over how those
interactions will be restructured what
the incentives will be for the different
agents and if you set it up in the right
way you can probably make Cooperative
outcomes more likely at least that would
be the idea but what we might be
imagining here is is that uh 20 years
from now I have an AI assistant and and
you have one too and these AI assistants
are autonomous to the extent that they
they can we can give them tasks and they
can go out in the world and solve these
tasks for us and perhaps in in their
business of solving these tasks they
have to cooperate or they have to to to
interact in a way where we don't want
them to say say you want the last bread
in the bakery and and I wanted to and
we've we've both given our our AIS the
task of fetching the bread for us we
don't want them to become violent or
confrontational uh we want them perhaps
to you know solve this problem in in a
way that that's more Cooperative is that
too fanciful or is that uh it's it's my
this is my attempt of trying to make
what we're talking about more concrete
here does that sound plausible
reasonable too yeah no that that's that
seems fine yeah um I mean in a way this
is this would just be an extension of of
the cooperation problem that you and I
would be having if we just were doing
this stuff
ourselves but as I was saying maybe
there's a way to set up those eight AI
agents and the structures regulations
institutions Norms laws that govern
their interactions in a way that makes
it easier for them to cooperate and
solve those cooperation problems
that then it would be for for humans to
do this because as humans we I mean just
have certain constraints I mean the the
sort of human minds and impulses and
behaviors are
well not entirely fixed but but some to
some degree they're
harder to change than if you have agents
like AI agents will be programmed from
scratch so I mean if you have if you
were able to program humans from scratch
it would also be easier to solve certain
cooperation problems because then they
could sort of just
edit out people with particularly
malevolent or sadistic or Psychopathic
impulses right and the point is that we
can't easily do that with humans uh but
when it comes to Future AI agents maybe
there will be more wiggle room to do
that sort of thing that that results in
more Cooperative outcomes perhaps one
one question that arises for me here is
is the question of how good can we
become at cooperating how good could
could future AIS become at cooperation
and are there limits built into perhaps
even physics or the mathematics of of
game theory that make it so that so that
you so that perfect cooperation or
Utopia of cooperation cannot really be
achieved so so I'm thinking for example
the future might be very good but it
will probably involve a resource
scarcity which makes it makes it the
case that is not always possible to
cooperate if if both parties want uh to
maximize their resources for example how
how far from from the ideal of of
perfect cooperation are humans and how
far from that ideal could ASP so so how
much better could they become at
cooperating than we are
I mean the corporation simply that
depends on the the circumstances right I
mean if you're if you're in a single
shot prisoners dilemma then the rational
thing to do is simply to defect and so I
mean there's a question of what exactly
does it mean for agents to be better or
worse at operating
and actually another issue is of course
that since those agents will be
intelligent I mean why wouldn't they
figure it out on their own sort of how
to handle those things so maybe I I'm I
find it more
um
helpful to think about it in terms of
how how can the the relevant
institutions lost and so on be set up to
to Foster Cooperative outcomes in those
interactions between AIS in much the
same way as we're doing it with perfumes
you know by having a police uh a legal
system and so on the rule of law that
sort of things
so you're thinking at it at cooperation
at the level of Institutions and not as
much as the at the level of Agents this
is at least how I'm in trying to think
about it but one can also do it
differently and just look at the the
more technical details of how like there
is just research on how artificial
agents do like if you use reinforcement
Learners how they do in in those
cooperation problems when they play an
integrated business that I'm something
like that against each other so let's
research on that and what you can how
can how you can modify them to achieve
more cooperative
outcomes um yeah so the data that is
definitely also a technical angle to
that in terms of AI governance uh have
you in your research found anything that
might help us reduce future suffering
the best focus of governance
interventions would be to focus on on
avoiding conflicts and fostering
cooperation similar to what I was
talking about with Cooperative AI I have
to admit that the question of how to
best do that on a practical level I mean
how do you actually get the different
AI Labs or possibly governments that are
involved to cooperate well I'm not I'm
not an expert on how to best do that on
a practical level there are certainly
people that are much better placed to to
answer that that like more practical
question but in terms of
but the goal should be I think that
avoiding conflicts and fostering
cooperation between the relevant actors
in this space that that seems to me a
very worthwhile and important goal of
like AI governance from an asterisk
perspective if we're thinking in
Practical terms do you think trying to
influence governments are overcrowded
and it perhaps especially so in the case
of AI where there are billions at stake
so a lot of people are interested in
influencing AI regulations do you think
that perhaps you or other with with your
interests will have a chance at
influencing these regulations it's uh
certainly not not going to be easy and I
mean another problem is of course that
we do not necessarily at this point know
so exactly what sort of regulations we
actually want or would be better in the
long term I wouldn't say that it's
overcrowded I mean it's probably still
less crowded than like
other more mainstream political
discourse maybe there are ways to have
leverage here if you can get the right
experts in the right committee or
whatever
to have influence on government policy I
think this is actually what some people
at fhi and the coffee I have done so
yeah this can be a legitimate strategy
to have an influence on the long term
future so I I think it's it makes sense
yeah if we're talking if we're still
talking governance but if we move on to
space governance do you think that we
should be trying or people who are
worried about reducing suffering in the
future should be trying to make like
legislation that makes it more difficult
to go to space or do you think that the
perhaps the public relations risk there
is too high because people would like a
Humanity to go to space it's exciting
perhaps people disagree with whether it
would lead to bad outcomes and so on I
would say that while I'm not entirely
dismissing the idea I'm relatively
skeptical about whether this is going to
be the best
approach
um it seems to me that in the relevant
scenarios it's probably quite difficult
to to prevent space colonization
altogether if if you're in a scenario
where people definitely want to do that
for whatever reason if you're thinking
in terms of marginal impact it seems
better for people who are interested in
Source production to boost for a more
prudent approach that takes asterisks
into account
rather than just trying to stop space
condensation altogether because as
you're saying that might be
controversial it's uh it might run into
a lot of opposition and and in that case
it's just better to try to you know if
you can't beat them join them and so
something like that
um but then again I'm not entirely
dismissing the idea either perhaps the
motivation to colonize space will be
limited anyway as we've discussed
um earlier perhaps opposition to it will
be popular I don't know perhaps the
sentiment will be make make earth great
again and
yeah in that case it could be a strategy
but as I'm saying like it's something
that to be careful about and likely not
the best
thing to do because it's kind of too
cross-grained and you probably want to
find better more specific levers they
would use asterisks also one of your
favorite paths to trying to reducing
suffering trying to reduce suffering is
trying to build the movement of people
who are interested in doing this and
trying to to research and gather
knowledge about how to do this in
practice one thing so this seems like a
like an audible goal this seems like a
great thing to do to to gain more
knowledge about our situation and
perhaps one thing that whether
incentives wouldn't be right is that
people who are who are interested in in
reducing suffering risks would be
perhaps motivated to find find out that
that we can actually do something and
would perhaps be reluctant to to admit
that maybe their research points in the
direction that that we can't really do
anything about uh reducing uh suffering
in the future do you think that's a do
you think that's a problem and do you
think that's that's especially a problem
for for suffering risks yeah or for me
personally
um yeah I mean this can be
a risk I mean with any sort of cause
area or idea I suppose there's a risk
that people will this is the people who
endorse it will sort of get stuck in
their ways get stuck in their way of
thinking and
cease to be open-minded about other
priorities so
I mean I'm definitely not saying that
I'm 100 sick on on this being the thing
to do I mean I don't know I could be
convinced uh by all sorts of arguments
that may be a different focus is more
fruitful and nevertheless at the moment
I I think it's it's worth thinking about
estrus I mean
it's good to have like I don't know a
handful of people looking at worst case
scenarios and what you can do about it
right I mean
out of 8 billion people on earth like it
would be good if like maybe 10 or 20
and look at that I I take your point do
you what do you think are the most uh
interesting unanswered questions when it
comes to suffering risks what are the
most fruitful areas of research if if
some of our listeners are interested in
in looking into to to these issues
themselves what what should they dig
into
um what what are some what is some what
are some questions that you would like
to have answered yeah I mean I think
some of the most
action relevant questions are to flesh
out in in more detail what the nature of
the most important suffering risks
are is actually a question that we sort
of skirted a little bit because it is a
very difficult question to answer and we
just at the moment don't really know and
like it's just distributed over many
different possibilities and and lots of
unknowns but like of course it would be
very valuable to know more about what
what classes of scenarios or classes of
outcomes actually contribute the most
suffering in expectation that that is
obviously a very important research
question to to look at then the other
question is well what are the most most
effective interventions we've discussed
some we've discussed in moral advocacy
we've discussed Cooperative AI but it's
it's of course still an open question
like which of those interventions is is
most impactful on the margin for
reducing asterisks I mean there are lots
of open questions as you can tell and I
mean I think it's more research on those
crucial questions
would be very valuable in my opinion and
indeed I think that the most important
thing to do now is like to research what
what we should do basically about
asterisks
fantastic that's a great way to end it
uh Tobias thank you for coming on the
podcast
thanks for having me